yeah sunglasses because it's the
sunshine the movie
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so sunshine this is a patreon
sponsored review because yes if you go
to my patreon it is possible to
Commission to me to review things that I
might not otherwise now this is a film
it's a sci-fi film directed by Danny
Boyle written by Alex garland who had
teamed previously on a number of things
including the Beach and 28 days later
and this it's kind of a forgotten Danny
Boyle film in a way I don't think people
forget that it exists but it's one of
those ones the people who like it keep
going you know why aren't more people
saying this is one of his best films and
then there's most other people going
it's okay
and up to this point I have really been
in the latter camp because the sort of
general consensus you know from the
people who aren't in absolute love with
this movie is that it kind of falls
apart I'm not completely but a bit in it
in the tail end and the third act and
that was definitely the impression that
I had when I saw it originally which I
missed into the theaters I think I
thought the leap the year after so it's
what it's been about a decade since I've
seen this maybe a little more but so
let's start with some explanation of
what sunshine even is because at this
point it's like it's a little bit of a
cult movie if people know it at all
so the premise is that the Sun is dying
it is gotten weaker and as a result the
human race the Earth's gotta become
uninhabitable and the human race is
gonna be wiped out and the film follows
the the crew of the Icarus technically
the Icarus to which is a ship that is
headed to the Sun with a payload of a
very specially designed bomb basically
designed to restore
the engine of the Sun and get it burning
more brightly again there is actually
some solid science behind the whole idea
it doesn't get into it too much you can
debate how hard or soft the science of
this is but it's certainly presented
fairly it's certainly presented to seem
like hard science it's presented very
matter-of-fact it's not al it's not a
bunch of whiz-bang kind of stuff it's
very it's very methodical I mean it's
it's Danny Boyle Tim whenever Danny
Boyle makes a film because I would
actually say especially if it's a
premise that seems like it might be
schlocky he's gonna give it a little bit
of a more thoughtful artistic spin and
he does here so we have this crew that
is headed for the Sun for this and
obviously they run into problems their
situations and then it's about halfway
in no it's earlier than halfway in the
movie that this initially comes up they
get a signal from Icarus one which was
thought to be lost no one ever knew what
happened to it and that ship is still
around putting out some kind of signal
and they don't know what's going on and
they have to make the decision whether
it is worth it to stop in for that or if
that is too risky and then of course
there's lots of things that go on from
there I am gonna be getting into
spoilers later but let's just start
broadly speaking it's a great cast in
this we and this was at the time this
came out I feel like Killian Murphy was
the biggest name at the time the movie
came out but it also has Chris Evans in
it it has Michelle Yeoh and well I guess
Michelle Yeoh depending on what country
you're in might have been a bigger name
but she's in it Benedict wong is in it
it's got Rose Byrne actually the woman
who played chantho in the Doctor Who
episode utopia is the voice of the
computer on the ship it's it's a really
it's a terrific cast from top to bottom
really talented compelling you know
charismatic the camera like really
some actors all over this thing and like
I said it has a fairly thoughtful fairly
methodical vibe to it it is for the most
part certainly for its first two thirds
presented in a kind of like a
fictionalized sort of Apollo 13 or you
know middle chunk of 2001 sort of vibe
it's it's doing things at a leisurely
pace occasionally stuff will pick up and
they'll have to deal with something
right away but where we're not turning
this into an action film we are letting
the tension of the situation just kind
of sit and the gravity of it and there's
also got a claustrophobic feel because
the movie doesn't it neither starts nor
does it cut back to as the movie goes
long earth to show you what it's like
there it is completely confined to the
ship which lends that greater sense of
claustrophobia and as it goes along it
does kind of shift and where it heads in
its third act it doesn't work but I for
me and I and knowing what was coming
this time I was really focusing and
really trying to see okay is there
ground work that I missed that makes
this work and I don't think there is I
don't think this last third of the movie
works and that is that is a significant
problem I'll get to specifics on that in
a minute when I started talking woes but
the performances are all good it looks
really good the sets are incredibly
convincing the science feels solid
there's a lot of great tension in the
performances and in the relationships
you know Chris Evans kind of steals the
show a bit out a few times because you
can get he is by far the most focus he's
the one saying no there is nothing that
we do to jeopardize this mission and we
are all expendable you know he's very
he's very much got that mindset and
there's there's a guy who characters of
Cyril who
is the the ship's psychiatrist and like
the the mental who like tried trying to
keep everybody keep their sanity and
he's like a little bit of an odd guy
aren't you and Michelle Yeoh keeping the
the oxygen garden tending to the plants
and that she obviously has poured her
heart and soul into keeping this stuff
going it's everybody feels like a fully
fleshed out character and the
performances are really good and there
and while I am about to launch into
criticisms of the talent the movie the
very end the final two scenes
effectively of the the resolution of the
immediate situation that the that the
film is dealing with and then the sort
of little epilogue scene that happens
after that are really good are really
wonderful and really gorgeous and a
really wonderful note to take the film
out on but most of that third act still
doesn't really work which means I need
to get into spoilers now so if you
haven't already seen the movie and I
would recommend giving it a shot even
though I if you haven't seen it before
if any of the sounded like it was up
your alley so again keep in mind more of
a hard sci-fi benen Alex Garland who
wrote it you know I mentioned some of
the other stuff you wrote that Danny
Boyle directed but he also wrote and
directed ex machina and annihilation so
like if that's him that's who Alex
Garland is and that's who wrote this so
if if his work and if stuff like that
appeals to you and you haven't seen this
movie before
go and give it a shot before you hear
what I have to say about this ending
because you deserve to to have the best
shot at enjoying it and here we go with
spoilers so it's been said that the tail
end turns into a bit of a slasher film
and that the tone doesn't fit I'm
actually going to disagree I think the
tonal shift doesn't completely fall down
where it falls down is who they turn
into the villain that I think honestly
is the straw that breaks the camel's
back because what we have at the tail
end is we have a character introduced
who basically has gone mad from
isolation and the just the weight of the
situation that he was in and he was the
captain character by the name of
hen backer played by mark strong and he
was the captain of the original Icarus
and he was the only survivor the rest of
the crew died it's not entirely clear
whether they killed themselves or if he
killed them it's a little bit up in the
air but he is dead he is dead set and
determined to stop the Icarus - to let
the earth die and he has these sort of
odd monologues you know saying like
there will be a moment when there was
only one one man left in the universe
and then that moment will pass will I be
that man and he also has a line like
I've spent the last seventy years
talking with God and and that's sort of
where the division comes and I did
actually look into this I don't usually
look into behind-the-scenes stuff but I
was trying to figure out if there was
something that I missed and I feel like
there's a split because what Alex
Garland wrote was something much more
philosophically minded he really wanted
to get into very existential questions
when having these characters deal with
these things and have you care to talk
about God was really for him the main
heart of the script that he wrote
whereas Danny Boyle made the decision to
downplay the more philosophical acts
elements and themes have that service
background and focus much more on the
more visceral stuff on the more
immediate things the threats of well
initially you know tech going wrong or
the fire breaking out and then you know
pinback ER and that loss of the more
philosophical elements I think is part
of why this falls down but honestly I
think I think the straw that breaks the
camel's back is the fact that pin
backers a character who we don't know
who gets introduced more or less out of
nowhere when they after they board the
Icarus one because we don't really have
a proper build to him and it makes even
less sense if you take into account that
it seems in a lot of ways like the film
was building Cyril the the the shrink as
headed down a similar mental path to the
one pin backer was on
I don't think it would have taken too
many tweaks to the script to remove pin
backer and have Cyril be the one who
snaps and then we have a character who
we know and who knows these other
characters and these how're established
relationships as opposed to psycho
killer comes out of nowhere halfway
through the film which is what happens
now what's motivating pin backer and
what is driving him and what has pushed
him to the edge that all works it's just
him specifically that doesn't if you
wanted to stretch credibility and you
know go for a slightly softer thing you
could have even made him the captain
somehow having survived but being
horrifically burned from what he had
from what he had to do to try and set
the the the panels back in place again
that would be as stretch and I wouldn't
actually advocate for that because that
in the the the science of the film is a
bit harder than what allows for that but
like I said I still think that would
have worked better than introducing this
guy who's just from nowhere and also I
don't think Danny Boyle's decision to
like never have him appear clearly and I
don't like me like hide him in shadows I
mean like every time he's in shot the
camera kind of shakes and it's blurred
out and the image is blown out and like
there's a couple shots where it works
and there's others like this just looks
weird and some of the decisions like
most of the things that I'm like yeah
center around this character so again I
think it could have worked if it was
just somebody else but because it isn't
there's a disconnect then it feels more
jarring than it should have and maybe it
would have worked better if the more
existential themes were still in the
film maybe I'm inclined to say that it
still really needed to not just be this
external character who came out of
nowhere especially because these ideas
of how
being out you know this long room with
this kind of mission and with this
highest-stakes just can break people
that stuff is underpinning a lot of
what's going on you see how in some ways
it breaks I mean in a very
self-destructive as opposed to outwardly
destructive way it breaks Benedict 1:1
when he makes a simple understandable
mistake he had a billion calculations he
had to do by hand to make a tiny
adjustment and he forgot one thing
and it almost cost the mission and the
weight of that broke him the film does
set up how crushing all of this can be
but you don't pay that off with a
character who just come comes out of
nowhere he just comes out of nowhere
this guy and it just it just doesn't
work and it's a shame because it's a
really well-made movie it's a really
well-executed movie but for this one
detail this one nugget doesn't sync the
movie but it does hold it back rather
significantly and it's a question I
think of how much it bothers you I've
seen some people make the argument that
it still kind of works but I've never
seen anyone make the argument that like
it makes the movie or it's a big part of
the point or it's their favorite element
I've seen people defend it but only in a
look it's not bad it actually works way
not in a no but it's so good way cuz I
it's not it was not the right call and
not because of tone just because of
details and I'm like I feel like one or
two more passes out the script might
have ironed this out but as it stands
this is the movie we have and what it
ends up being is a movie that is really
good for about two-thirds and then it
becomes just pretty good for the home
stretch until those last two scenes the
detonation of the bomb and the one shot
the one scene we get on earth afterwards
of this frozen ocean and the Sydney
Opera House and the Sun getting a little
brighter that's beautiful that's a
terrific ending and it helps bring it
back up just a tad but ya know pin
backer doesn't work so that's sunshine
you seen it would you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it as a bunch of stuff to do
down there as well cuz you can support
me through patreon through PayPal
whatever you feel like doing helps me
cover my bills plus there's a bunch of
other stuff down there as well there's
my socials and all that stuff check them
out
click things there's the like I
appreciate that subscribe if you haven't
share this or don't do any of it if you
don't feel like it I mean I appreciate
it I've encouraged it but I'm not gonna
tell you what to do because at the end
of the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]